pronto estos cultivos de caña podrían
ser reemplazados por hectáreas de
marihuana los campesinos de tetecala
morelos al sur de méxico están decididos
a aprovechar un fallo de la suprema
corte que despenalizó el uso lúdico de
la cannabis para sembrarla y detonar el
desarrollo de su pueblo
mi modo de
esto de la marihuana como dije como es
una pequeña ayuda al bolsillo pues no
pienso sembrar toda la parcela así
parece que para empezar con una tarea
que se sembrará con necesaria máscara
porque prácticamente vamos a hacer el
punta de lanza nosotros aquí en morelos
como cándido josé velázquez ya está
preparado pero él va más allá queremos
sembrar la cannabis para sacar productos
para la salud
también para que nuestro pueblo tenga la
oportunidad de que la gente que venga a
conocer nuestros programas sea parte del
turismo que necesitamos en este
municipio
el activista alejandro velo llevó a los
campesinos a la sede local de la
comisión federal contra riesgos
sanitarios a solicitar licencias de
siembra ahora esperan respuesta y
advierte que si es negativa irán a la
suprema corte su visión no es sólo
sembrar sino convertir al pueblo en un
polo turístico y sea pues bueno primero
habíamos dicho el primer pueblo
cannábico de mexico después nos dimos
cuenta que sería de toda latinoamérica y
lo que buscamos es ser el segundo lugar
más visitado del mundo en cuestión de
marihuana únicamente después de
ámsterdam habitantes y ejidatarios
aseguran que ya es hora de que lleguen
las oportunidades que los políticos no
les han brindado por lo que si su
proyecto cannábico prospera harán que
los beneficios alcancen para toda la
comunidad